bonsoir et bienvenue invité exceptionnel
de savon garde ce soir il y a Lebrun
pivée bonsoir bonsoir et merci d'être là
il y a un an jour pour jour vous étiez
élu au perchoir par les députés à
l'Assemblée nationale première femme
présidente vous entriez dans l'histoire
c'est évidemment une journée très
particulière pour vous l'occasion de
faire le bilan pour LCP de cette année
parlementaire pas comme des autres
l'assemblée a fait preuve du meilleur
comme du pire on va en parler elle les
attendent des Français sont immenses et
d'actualité très chargées on va revenir
sur le drame de Nanterre et ce jeune de
17 ans tué par un policier une minute de
silence a été observée dans l'hémicycle
aujourd'hui une heure avec elle brune
Pivet on y va c'est parti
[Musique]
éruptive incontrôlable ou bloqué on a
tout entendu sur cette nouvelle
Assemblée nationale que vous présidez
Yaël Braun Pivet et pourtant pourtant un
an après elle fonctionne bel et bien on
va le voir mais à quel prix alors pour
dresser le bilan ce soir trois
chroniquesurs trois invités
m'accompagnent elles à mon Agava bonsoir
et merci d'être là de la rédaction delcp
vous allez revenir sur le bilan des
réformes adoptées bonsoir Pierre-Adrien
Bartoli daris interactive qui vous
parlera madame la Présidente de l'image
de l'Assemblée nationale étude d'opinion
à l'appui et puis le politologue Loïc
biondio bonsoir professeur de sciences
politiques à la Sorbonne qui va
dialoguer avec vous sur la réforme des
institutions vous faites de nombreuses
propositions mais on commence comme
chaque soir par le biais de Stéphane
blackowski dont la peau de brune Pivet
c'est un défi et c'est à lui
et je me retourne comme chaque soir pour
vous accueillir je vous invite à faire
la même chose et elbron Pivet bonsoir
Stéphane bonsoir Myriam bonsoir madame
le Président bonsoir à toutes et tous
alors cette année il y a un an il y a le
bonnet vous entriez dans l'histoire
c'est notre Grand Journal du monde le
monde qui le disait très solennellement
vous voyez le problème c'est avant
d'être reconnu par l'apostérité il faut
déjà être reconnu par ses contemporains
et oui et ça au niveau de TF1 RTL qui
sont plus grand public ils saluaient la
première bien sûr mais il se posait
quand même une question mais qui est bon
sang Yaël Braun Pivet alors pour vous
faire connaître vous avez commencé par
démontrer ou vouloir vous avez commencé
par vouloir démontrer votre indépendance
par rapport à l'exécutif alors deux
exemples ça c'était en septembre quand
le gouvernance disait tiens si on
faisait passer la réforme des retraites
par un amendement allez hop là direct
vous avez dit non et puis ensuite c'est
carrément le président qui lançait son
CNR Conseil national de la refondation
et là aussi pareil vous n'êtes pas des
mots vous avez dit stop il s'agirait pas
d'empiéter sur les plates bandes de
l'assemblée et donc même pour démontrer
voilà votre impartialité à votre poste
vous avez même été jusqu'à faire des
rappels à l'ordre contre les députés de
votre propre camp notamment quand l'une
d'entre elles avaient dénoncé l'ADN
xénophobe du RN on écoute
panneau je me vois contraintes de
prononcer un rappel alors parce que vous
avez utilisé à la tribune le mot
xénophobe à l'égard d'un parti politique
je venais de rappeler qu'il fallait
avoir une attitude respectueuse les uns
envers les autres
le résultat de cette indépendance là
c'est que en décembre on apprenait dans
l'Express c'était le titre de l'article
rien ne va plus entre Yelle Braun pide
et la majorité oui on avait trouvé que
vous étiez trop indépendante et
consécration pour vous toujours notre
grand journal du soir vous dressez un
portrait ou on vous qualifiait donc de
présidente mon alignés capables de tenir
la dragée haute à l'Élysée mais bon ça
évidemment c'était en décembre il y a 6
mois et depuis il y a eu la réforme des
retraites et forcément pour quelqu'un
qui rêvait que l'assemblée soit
l'endroit où on peut débattre sans se
battre vous avez dû un petit peu tomber
de vous j'imagine alors faut dire que la
nuit pêche elle avait choisi de se
mettre un peu au diapason de la colère
de la rue donc de votre côté vous avez
multiplier les sanctions plus de 90 au
total et 68 en un seul jour ce fameux
jour où en plus de chanter la
Marseillaise les députés IPS avaient
brandi une affichée alors à qui la faute
est-ce que c'est le gouvernement qui
refuse le dialogue ou est-ce que c'est
l'opposition qui empêche le débat je me
garderai bien de me prononcer ce qui est
sûr c'est que de ce de cette débat
l'assemblée n'est pas sorti grandit vous
voyez sur les sondages qui datent du
début de l'année ou une majorité de
Français était choquée par la tournure
des débats et même plus embarrassant sur
une période d'un an la côte de confiance
de l'Assemblée qui était déjà plutôt en
bas de la liste a perdu en un seul coup
dix points alors vous-même vous n'êtes
pas tout à fait sorti indemne de cette
réforme parce que votre réputation
d'indépendance d'impartialité que vous
aviez commencé à construire on a pris un
coup évidemment quand vous avez sorti
l'article 40 pour empêcher le vote sur
le recul à 64 ans on va donc écouter les
reproches que vous avez fait à ce
moment-là l'un des députés les plus
respectés de l'Assemblée le président
Chassaigne
le choix que vous avez fait madame la
Présidente de recourir à l'article 40
porte un coup terrible à notre
démocratie parlementaire vous abîmer
vous écrabouillez la démocratie
parlementaire et vous surtout il y a une
chose que vous oubliez c'est la
séparation des pouvoirs
alors c'est quand même assez dur
d'encaisser ce genre de reproche alors
mes manifestement c'est la bonne
nouvelle vous n'êtes pas rancunière
parce que j'ai lu dans Le Parisien
dimanche que vous étiez prête à faire
rentrer André Chassagne au gouvernement
au poste de ministre de l'Agriculture et
là je me suis dit mais c'est peut-être
la dernière macroniste de ce pays au
moment où la majorité me salit avec la
droite non et encore une personne qui
croit que on peut être en même temps de
gauche et de droite on peut débattre
sans se battre bon j'espère que vous
allez pouvoir prouver que ce rêve est
possible il vous reste quatre ans pour
le prouver à moins bien sûr d'une des
solutions ça merci beaucoup Stéphane une
petite réaction pour commencer la
dernière des macronistes ça vous va
ça me va mais je veux pas être la
dernière parce que ça voudrait dire que
je serai la seule peut-être et donc ça
ça n'est pas possible moi je crois au
dépassement des clivages je crois
surtout au rassemblement des défis il
est possible dans cette nouvelle opinion
et nous y arrivons nous y arrivons tous
les jours vous savez donc cela est
possible nous le démontrons et nous
produisons de très belles choses dans
cette assemblée beaucoup de textes votés
à l'unanimité ou à une quasi unanimité
revenir dans le détail on va y revenir
mais je crois avec l'opposition on
entendait André Chassaigne c'est vrai
que c'est une voix forte et les députés
depuis des années au Palais Bourbon on
renout le dialogue facilement et le
dialogue n'est jamais brisé avec
personne et donc avec André Chassaigne
nous travaillons très bien ensemble avec
cette gauche qui vous bien sûr vous a
traité de partiel et de la Présidente
il y a beaucoup de postures chez les uns
et les autres chez les géopolitiques et
c'est le jeu de notre Assemblée
nationale que vous connaissez très bien
mais ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que avec
chacun des présidents de groupe et avec
chaque parlementaire le dialogue n'est
jamais rompu parce que je crois que je
suis convaincu que chacun a conscience
de la responsabilité qui pèse sur ses
épaules et être dans le lieu du débat
par excellence et refuser le débat et
prenez la rupture ça n'est je crois dans
l'esprit de personne avant de donner la
parole à mes camarades et à mes invités
un petit mot sur cette double casquette
au Royaume-Uni le speaker de la Chambre
des communes britanniques se met en
retraite sont partis parce que de fait
l'indépendance est attachée à la
fonction de président de l'Assemblée
mais vous êtes aussi solidaire d'un
gouvernement où vous faites partie de
renaissance est-ce que c'est pas un
exemple à suivre je crois pas je crois
pas parce que déjà c'est très artificiel
en fait ah oui demander à un homme ou
une femme politique de se mettre en
retraite son parti politique à un moment
où il exerce des responsabilités
éminentes c'est complètement antinomique
en revanche être assuré que lorsque je
prends des décisions en tant que
président de l'Assemblée nationale je le
fais en toute impartialité et en me
dégageant d'une appartenance partisane
ça c'était essentiel et c'est ce que je
m'efforce de faire depuis un an de bien
faire la distinction entre les deux et
je pense en tout cas moi je suis
convaincu d'y arriver ça n'est pas
facile ça n'est pas facile et le chemin
parfois est extrêmement on va avoir que
le chemin il est il est compliqué on va
tout de suite passer à notre première
séquence sur les réformes adoptées à
l'Assemblée nationale elles amont
d'agabar au bar entré dans le détail
mais si elle ne résume pas cette année
parlementaire que vous vouliez ou non
c'est la réforme qui marquera les
Français et les audiences LCP en
témoignent la réforme des retraites la
mère des batailles et le point d'orgue
du dindé d'affrontement dans l'hémicycle
Clément Pergaud rembobine pour nous
regarder
[Musique]
vous n'avez pas frappé les pupitres la
parole est au gouvernement des
engagements présidentielles
on n'est pas dans une manif on est dans
l'hémicycle de l'Assemblée nationale
nous y sommes au fil de l'examen
l'attention va encore monter crescendo
notamment avec les députés insoumis
ce sont les mots d'un bourreau entre
2017 et 2019 c'est 33% d'accidents du
travail causant la mort en plus et vous
avez la responsabilité de ces choix
politiques vous êtes un imposteur et un
assassin
ces propos vaudront au députés Aurélien
saint-oule un rappel à l'ordre la
virulence de certaines attaques a semblé
affectées Olivier du soft à la fin de
l'examen le ministre du Travail
s'emporte dans l'hémicycle mesdames et
messieurs les députés insoumis vous
m'avez insulté 15 jours vous sortez mais
vous m'avez insulté personne n'a craqué
personne n'a craqué et nous sommes là
devant vous pour la réforme au moment du
vote définitif le gouvernement décide
d'utiliser le 49-3 et l'hémicycle ce
jour-là est un chaudron en pleine
ébullition
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
depuis le début de l'année parlementaire
91 sanctions ont été prononcées contre
des députés dont 79 pendant le seul
examen de la réforme des retraites
quand on revoit toutes ces images on se
dit un peu comme un type de panneau
finalement 4 ans comme ça est-ce que
c'est possible quand on voit ces images
on se dit que non mais moi l'année que
j'ai vécu à l'Assemblée nationale ça
n'est absolument pas
représenté par ces images elle semblait
nationale pendant cette année a beaucoup
travaillé nous avons voté 32 textes de
façon définitive nous avons un taux de
d'accord avec le Sénat jamais atteint
nous avons voté des textes qui sont
utiles aux Français la hausse du pouvoir
d'achat à la hausse du point d'indice
nous avons travaillé et voté la
décongélisation
ne se cristallise pas autour de ça et
bien je veux pas vous apprendre votre
métier mais je trouve que quand on dit
le bilan d'un an dans son
la réforme des retraites et ben non
alors c'est pas ça et je suis sûr que
vous allez y venir parce que vous qui
connaissez l'assemblée vous savez que
l'assemblée est capable du meilleur moi
aujourd'hui j'ai réuni le bureau de
l'Assemblée nationale qui est l'instant
la plus importante de l'assemblée et qui
regroupe l'ensemble des partis
politiques et bien le bureau pour la
deuxième fois vient de voter à
l'unanimité le budget de l'Assemblée
nationale à l'unanimité je viens de
procéder à la nomination du
fonctionnaire le plus important de
l'Assemblée nationale le secrétaire
général et la proposition de nomination
a été adoptée à l'unanime ça veut dire
qu'en fait il est compromis pour
fonctionner ils sont là mais quand il
s'agit de s'opposer sur une réforme
aussi importante alors là c'est plus
possible face à face c'est qui est
responsable de ça le premier on a
l'impression quand même que tout le
monde est perdant mais tout le monde est
perdant parce que effectivement on
finalement on résume la vie de notre
assemblée à cela ça n'est pas ça on
résume la vie de notre assemblée au
chaos et aux insultes quiconque regarde
la vie de l'Assemblée dans un moment
autre que ce type de réforme constate
que dans l'hémicycle ça dialogue ça
dépend justement ça vote on fait le
bilan et donc c'est ça qu'il faut
regarder et il faut dézoomer en fait on
va dézoomer justement avec elles amont
d'un Gava dans le détail évidemment
cette réforme ne résume pas l'année
parlementaire oui et c'est une
expression que vous avez l'habitude
d'utiliser il y a helbron pivée quand
vous rencontrez des élus ou des Français
un peu comme dans un mariage c'est pour
le meilleur et pour le pire ici à
l'Assemblée le pire c'est peut-être ce
qu'on a vu le tumulte la tension
permanente le meilleur il y a peut-être
un chiffre qui va le résumer pour vous
c'est 68 68 textes définitivement
adoptés c'est tout confondu un projet de
loi proposition loi proposition de
résolution pour vous il y a le bon pivot
on imagine que c'est la preuve que cette
assemblée elle fonctionne j'ai envie de
dire malgré tout alors on peut citer
quelques textes pas tous mais il y en a
eu un sur l'assurance chômage il y a eu
la loop me qui a renforcé les moyens du
ministère de l'Intérieur sur les
énergies il y a eu lieu en même temps
macroniste un peu plus de nucléaires un
peu plus d'énergie renouvelable et puis
il y a eu aussi je crois que c'est
important pour vous des initiatives
parlementaires une proposition de loi
pour constitutionnaliser l'IVG ou encore
une autre pour lutter contre les dérives
des influenceurs tout ça certifié 100%
149,3 et on doit le rappeler malgré tout
sur les budgets le budget le budget de
la Sécurité sociale et on l'a vu sur la
réforme de retraite et bien 11 reprises
l'article 49 aliné à trois de la
Constitution a été utilisée par le
gouvernement on en reparlera si on
regarde dans le détail puisqu'on l'a dit
redit vous disposez que d'une majorité
relative c'est souvent la droite qui
vous permet d'avoir la pointe voie
nécessaire dans 64% des cas sur les
textes importants les camarades
d'érectiontier et d'Olivier Marleix et
bien sont en soutien du gouvernement si
on regarde du côté de la nupesse
l'opposition elle est bien plus franche
même s'il y a quelques disparités les
socialistes notamment s'abstiennent à de
nombreuses reprises il y a une autre
chose qu'on peut noter c'est le
rassemblement national on a énormément
parlé de la normalisation du parti avec
son entrée à l'Assemblée il y a tout de
même un le fond de verre pour le groupe
de Marine Le Pen c'est que les députés
des autres camps ne veulent pas voter
leurs proposition voilà c'est le
panorama de l'Assemblée c'est aussi la
partie que vous voulez montrer mais
est-ce que ce bilan qui existe vous
arrivez à le défendre auprès des
Français quand eux ne retiennent que le
49-3 qu'il perçoit on le verra comme un
passage en force mais en fait il faut le
défendre mais avant de le défendre il
faut le faire connaître et donc je
remercie d'avoir pris le temps de le
faire parce que inlassablement il faut
expliquer ce qu'est la vie de
l'assemblée et ce qu'elle peut produire
de bien comme de de pas bien et avoir
cette vision nuancée de l'Assemblée
nationale c'est mieux coller à la
réalité de ce qu'elle est et donc je
crois que il faut en convaincre nos
compatriotes notre Assemblée nationale
fonctionne elle leur réutilisent parce
que elle a voté un certain nombre de
textes qui sont qui rentrent directement
dans la vie des gens alors
projette vers l'avenir puisqu'on fait un
bilan pour mieux réussir à réformer ce
pays dans cette assemblée qui cherche
texte par text une majorité il faut
tendre la main plus généreusement et
beaucoup plus fortement vous savez qu'il
y a dit ça Nicolas Sarko Nicolas Sarkozy
c'était hier à la question lors d'un
déjeuner avec une partie des députés
renaissance des députés de la majorité
macroniste alors est-ce que c'est une
idée que vous partagez une coalition
avec les républicains moi je partage
l'idée d'un plus grand rassemblement de
vous savez quand on est en majorité
relative mais quand on est au
responsabilités on a nous le devoir de
ton amant et on a le devoir de
rassembler ça ne veut pas dire que nous
vous souhaitons
finalement absorber
vous voyez ce que je veux dire c'est pas
il ne s'agit pas de que tout une
condition ça existe tout le monde le
fait ça fait partie de leur culture de
compromis quand vous avez deux tiers des
députés les républicains sur les textes
il y a deux tiers des textes votés grâce
aux voix des LR il y a une traduction
politique peut-être à faire tout
simplement et se mettre autour d'une
table en essayant de trouver un
programme de gouvernement mais si il
s'agit de faire adopter les textes on a
vu que nous n'avons pas besoin de faire
une coalition les textes nous y arrivons
nous parvenons à obtenir des majorités
larges et pas seulement avec les plus
apaisée avec l'ensemble de l'Assemblée
nationale moi je crois qu'il faut
continuer dans cette direction là
chercher des majorités le plus larges
possible pas seulement à droite la
coalition elle a elle a du sens non pas
pour faciliter l'adoption de texte elle
a du sens si nous avons des valeurs
communes si nous partageons des
objectifs communs et là effectivement il
est intéressant que nous travaillons
ensemble mais moi je ne renonce pas la
promesse macroniste d'origine et donc le
rassemblement je veux qu'il porte à
droite et à gauche le dépassement on
l'entend Elsa il y a d'autres députés
qui surveillent bien les équilibres
politiques parce que l'histoire
macronise c'est voilà on peut gagner ce
qu'on perd d'un côté comme de l'autre
exactement c'est l'algorce des
macronistes ou alors eux ils se
réclament plutôt macroniste canal
historique qui disent attention à pas
trop se rapprocher de la droite on le
voit notamment sur le projet de loi
immigration les négociations sont en
cours et ce qu'à force de trop négocier
à droite vous risquez pas de perdre des
voix dans votre propre camp le risque
c'est surtout de s'asseoir finalement
sur nos valeurs et sur ce que l'on porte
et les objectifs que l'on souhaite
atteindre donc il faut évidemment
rechercher des compromis c'est notre
responsabilité première puisque nous
sommes aux responsabilités mais c'est
compromis ne doivent pas se faire au
sacrifie en sacrifiant nos valeurs
est-ce que pour vous le titre de séjour
métier en tension qui pour la droite
c'est non est-ce que vous dites il faut
impérativement que ce soit dans la
version finale du texte ça fait partie
des éléments qui équilibrent le texte et
qui en font à mon sens un texte dont on
a besoin et qui est juste et s'il n'y a
pas de majorité le 49-3 c'est un recours
possible nous verrons bien moi je fais
partie de ces optimistes qui pensent que
le débat parlementaire est utile et sert
à quelque chose et donc je ne juge pas
de
l'issue de ces débats c'est à ça les
débats ne sont jamais vains d'un mot
Elsa on se continue à se projeter il y a
pas mal de rendez-vous clés à la rentrée
à l'Assemblée oui le renouvellement des
postes importants présidente commission
vice-président Kester secrétaire alors
normalement chaque année c'est quasiment
une tacite reconduction là on va les
surveiller à la rentrée puisque il y en
a qui vont faire débattre on pense au
cacoquerel Éric Coquerel c'est le
président de la commission des finances
président insoumis la majorité lui
reproche de ne pas avoir activé le
fameux article 40 lire recevabilité
financière sur la proposition loi pour
abroger la réforme des retraites est-ce
que d'après vous il peut est-ce qu'il
doit rester à son poste à
les commissaires aux finances qui en
décideront ce qui est certain c'est
qu'effectivement nous avons eu un
profond désaccord avec le président
Coquerel sur l'application de l'article
40 et donc j'ai dû moi-même déclaré
recevable cet article 1 alors que très
clairement il aurait dû le faire avant
que le texte arrive en commission cette
divergence de vue sur l'article 40 ce
n'est pas isolé n'est pas unique
malheureusement à plusieurs reprises
j'ai dû intervenir après les
commissaires aux finances voteront et
décideront mais en tout cas ce qui est
très important et fondamental sur lequel
il ne faut pas transiger c'est
évidemment la présidence à l'opposition
c'est la règle l'usage c'est que les
députés de la majorité ne prennent pas
par au vote vous savez que si vous
voulez vous débarrasser des risques
Coquerel il faudra transgresser cet
usage et voter effectivement et donc
vous êtes prêts vous êtes prêts moi je
ne vote pas en commission des finances
bien allez on avance je voudrais vous
faire écouter un ancien Premier ministre
vous réagissez puis on parlera ensuite
de l'image de l'assemblée
gouverner
gouverner enfin devient la priorité
quand nous n'avons pas cessé nous
n'avons pas cessé de croire qu'il
fallait à tout prix réformer
gouverner ça passe avant réformé
gouverner c'est remettre de l'ordre chez
soi et pour cela on n'a pas besoin de
faire passer des lois
c'est vrai que on entend cette petite
musique au fond il faut incarner
politiquement gouverner tenir son
administration et arrêter de réformer il
a complètement tort Dominique de
Villepin non il a grandement raison
c'est ce que j'écrivais dans mon
plaidoyer pour un parlement renforcé on
croit depuis trop longtemps que
justement gouverner c'est faire une loi
que pour porter une politique il faut
nécessairement porter un texte à
l'Assemblée nationale et au Sénat je
crois que c'est une erreur les textes
sont évidemment importants mais ils
doivent être vu que comme un moyen pas
comme une fin en soi et faire de la
politique c'est autre chose c'est porter
des valeurs c'est porter des objectifs
c'est les incarner et c'est aussi être
capable de fédérer les énergies derrière
ces objectifs d'entraîner les gens de
convaincre du bien fondé de tel ou telle
politique c'est piloter et une
administration c'est beaucoup de choses
ça n'est pas
depuis un an je vous donne la parole
dans un instant mais d'abord on va les
entendre les Français Marco poli a
demandé aux visiteurs de l'Assemblée ce
qu'ils retiennent de cette année
parlementaire regardez
si vous mettez à la fille dehors ça sera
peut-être de bon niveau je suis un peu
agacé par le commentaire politique qui
est fait par la majorité et par des
journalistes qui reprennent ça en disant
que l'opposition ne respecterait pas
la dignité de la République etc on peut
délibérer de façon plus nuancée de façon
même s'ils sont contre je suis d'accord
ils sont contre et alors c'est une façon
pour invectiver les gens pour empêcher
le débat de ce produire non nous par
exemple au lycée on arrive à avoir des
débats qui sont très constructifs en
s'écoutant les uns les autres alors si
des ados peuvent le faire pourtant on
est enfin on est tout feu tout flamme
quand on est ado si des ados peuvent le
faire comment des adultes qui sont
encore plus instruits qui ont des années
et des années d'études dans les plus
prestigieuses université n'y arrivent
pas on peut penser que c'est négatif le
fait que ça se répercute nationale et
que ça ça soit aussi dans la nationale
cette colère mais peut-être que c'est
bien aussi quelque part que
je sais pas j'ai cette ambiguïté je me
dis oui c'est pas joli ce qu'on voit
c'est pas mais quelque part aussi c'est
c'est notre société quoi
[Musique]
ce sont eux qui ont voté qui l'ont élu
donc ça représente les Français en fait
le peuple moi je trouve pas qu'il soit
représenté
par les idées moi j'ai député représente
mal les citoyens aujourd'hui en France
complètement
et sur quel sujet par exemple retraite
pour ma part j'ai l'impression qu'ils
sont un petit peu dans leur tour de
verre après je pense que c'est aux
citoyen d'aller aussi enfin bien sûr le
député de aller vers les citoyen mais si
le soleil a fait pas l'effort d'aller
voir son député ou de s'y intéresser on
va pas mettre tous les tout sur le
député en disant qu'il est tard ça
je pense qu'il y a une facilité en
France à dire dès qu'il y a un problème
c'est la faute du régime c'est la faute
des institutions c'est je n'avais jamais
la faute des personnes finalement ce qui
est peut-être un peu le problème donc il
faut peut-être réfléchir à ça et arrêter
de vouloir changer de République tous
les 50 ans être plus près de des
citoyens être à l'écoute du citoyen des
référendum demander aux citoyens
qu'est-ce qu'ils qu'est-ce qui
souhaitent pour leur pays quelle loi
serait intéressante à partir du moment
on participe on accepte mieux les choses
imposer ça n'a jamais été une bonne
chose et aujourd'hui on subit voilà il y
a beaucoup de sujets qu'on retrouve dans
ces Paroles de Français notamment sur
l'association du citoyen le Blondieau on
en parle dans un instant alors
Pierre-Adrien Bartoli dites nous que
pense les Français de l'Assemblée
nationale sur cette année passée vous le
disiez le tout au long de cette année
cette première année de législature on a
interrogé les Français pour comprendre
quelle était cette image de l'Assemblée
évidemment comment elle évoluée au début
l'image était positive et une forme de
de confiance dans l'assemblée une forme
d'optimisme presque on se disait au fond
cette nouvelle assemblée
on se dit qu'elle a la capacité à
changer les choses elle a la capacité à
changer notre vie nous en tant que
Français à 61% et c'est le premier
chiffre que je voulais vous montrer
aujourd'hui donc un élan d'optimisme qui
est allé de pair avec la composition de
cette assemblée et la composition de
cette assemblée c'est évidemment une
situation de majorité relative qui est
une situation nouvelle pour les Français
qui n'ont pas accueilli avec différence
avec distance mais au contraire avec un
certain forme d'entrain en se disant
c'est une bonne chose parce que
différentes opinions vont pouvoir être
représentés à l'Assemblée et surtout on
va pouvoir y faire des compromis on a
deux tiers des Français c'est-à-dire 65
% qui nous indiquent oui c'est une bonne
chose d'avoir une majorité relative à
l'Assemblée avec néanmoins deux attentes
des attentes qui sont fortes qui sont
lourdes une attente pour les oppositions
quand on regarde que nous disent non
seulement l'ensemble des Français mais
aussi les sympathisants des parties
d'opposition que ce soit par exemple au
rassemblement national ou bien chez la
France insoumise dans les deux cas c'est
une minorité de ces sympathisants qui
souhaitent une opposition systématique
au projet de loi porté par le
gouvernement la majorité elle veut
pouvoir parfois trouver des arrangements
pas tout le temps évidemment mais ça
peut arriver mais aussi des attentes
très fortes du côté de la majorité et du
gouvernement avec cette idée qu'il faut
co-construire ces projets qui vont être
mis sur la table et évidemment une ligne
rouge très claire dans leur esprit dès
le départ c'est évidemment le 49-3 avant
même la première utilisation donc
vraiment au tout début de la législature
on a posé la question française majorité
relative oui il existe le 49-3 est-ce
qu'il faut l'utiliser dès le départ on
est très loin des retraites encore 71%
nous disait non il ne faut pas y aller
c'est la ligne rouge et on connaît
évidemment la suite de l'histoire ce qui
a créé une forme de de frustration de
tension au sein de la société française
qui nous emmène il y a quelques semaines
à poser la question du bilan on leur a
demandé non pas dans son ensemble mais
groupe par groupe si les français
étaient satisfaits ou non de leur député
et là les réponses sont extrêmement
claires aucun groupe ne bénéficie de la
confiance d'une majorité
des Français pire tous ces groupes sont
en dessous du Tiers de Confiance sauf un
il y en a un qui distingue un tout petit
peu du lot c'est le rassemblement
national avec 37% de confiance alors
justement pour rebondir sur ce dernier
chiffre et on va revenir sur les
enseignements de ce sondage on a
beaucoup dit voilà 88 députés la
stratégie de la normalisation la fameuse
cravate c'est un tremplin pour ses
députés
l'Assemblée nationale est-ce que pour
vous c'est un parti comme les autres
aujourd'hui je ne sais pas si c'est un
tremplin je ne le souhaite pas
après c'est le respect c'est le choix
des électeurs ça vous surprend ces
chiffres-là on disait toujours
rappelez-vous que il y avait un plafond
que le scrutin majoritaire en fait
faisait que il n'y aurait pas ou peu
d'élections de députés radicaux en fait
part et d'autre et on voit que ce
plafond a explosé et avec un scrutin
majoritaire on a beaucoup de radicalité
Assemblée nationale alors pour des
raisons différentes d'un côté il y a la
nupaise qui a organisé en fait les
candidatures sur les territoires en
candidatures uniques et de l'autre côté
on a le rassemblement national qui
réussit à s'implanter et donc c'est ça
effectivement c'est moi ça m'inquiète en
tant que femme politique mais après mon
rôle de président de l'Assemblée
nationale c'est de m'assurer que le
choix des électeurs est respecté et donc
d'assurer un traitement égal à tout
député quel que soit leur parti
politique et ce fameux compromis qui est
réclamé ça s'est très intéressant dans
ce sondage par pratiquement tous les
Français quel que soit leur sensibilité
politique seule 35% des proches du parti
des insoumis considèrent qu'il faut
faire une opposition systématique ça m'a
surprise moi de découvrir ça ça veut
dire qu'ils n'ont rien compris mais
surtout ça veut dire qu'on est que je
suis sur la bonne voie parce que moi je
le répète un massablement depuis un an
c'est que ce que les Français veulent
ils veulent qu'on discute ils veulent
qu'on échange ils veulent qu'on débatte
et ils veulent qu'on travaille ensemble
dans leur intérêt nous n'avons pas de
temps à perdre les sujets sont trop
importants et c'est pour ça que
j'insiste beaucoup sur le fait que nous
adoptons des textes à l'unanimité que
nous trouvons des majorités parce que
sur les projets
les écologistes ont voté 0 projet de loi
toujours contre mais les communes
contrairement aux socialistes voilà et
contrairement aux communistes qui ont
fait aussi des abstentions qui donc on
arrive à trouver un chemin c'est
difficile mais moi j'invite chacun à
prendre ses responsabilités le sondage
que vous évoquez me conforte en ce sens
c'est ce qu'attendent les Français c'est
ce qu'attendent les Français de nous et
donc à nous de nous montrer à la hauteur
de leurs attentes et de de l'élection et
de la mission qu'ils nous ont confié
vous savez moi je le dis souvent nous
sommes porteurs d'un mandat nous
n'agissons pas pour notre propre compte
nous agissons pour le contre de pour le
compte des Français pour le compte de
nos électeurs dans l'intérêt général et
donc cela nous impose d'aller chercher
des compromis parce que sinon nous ne
remplirions pas la mission qui nous ont
confié
un petit mot Pierre-Adrien Bartoli
peut-être sur le 49.3
la séquence on se rend bien compte qu'il
y a déjà une crise passion préalable
autour de cet objet de 49-3 qui est pas
parfaitement défini mais dont on sent
qu'il a quelque chose qui est perçu
comme antidémocratique la réalité est
évidemment autre chose en tout cas perçu
par les Français comme un passage en
force et surtout sur la réforme des
retraites on sent que dans la séquence
le 49-3 fait la bascule c'est à dire
qu'il y a une transformation de ce qui
est la mobilisation contre la réforme
des traces à ce moment-là qui passe d'un
mouvement assez traditionnel fort mais
traditionnel contre un projet à une
interrogation beaucoup plus profonde
plus transverse sur la manière dont on
est gouverné voir si les élargies la
manière dont on est pris en compte dans
la société c'est vrai mais en même temps
vous voyez le 49-3 et la résultante de
la majorité relative
puisque il a été prévu dès l'origine
pour servir dans ce type de situation et
nous nous savions dès le départ que sur
les questions par exemple budgétaires
nous n'aurions pas de capacité à avoir
une adoption à une majorité absolue
puisque nous n'en disposons pas et que
le vote du budget est structurant du
fait de savoir si vous êtes dans la
majorité ou dans l'opposition pour vous
donc il est indispensable dans une
situation de majorité relative qui a
souhaité par les Français mais il nous
faut trouver les bons équilibres moi je
crois qu'en 2008 nous les avons trouvés
avec la réforme portée par Nicolas
Sarkozy qui était de dire il faut en
limiter drastiquement l'usage en période
ordinaire donc sur des textes classiques
mais en revanche en période budgétaire
ne le mitons pas puisque ça peut on peut
être dans une situation on a besoin de
l'utiliser pour simplement doter le pays
aujourd'hui un budget par session hors
budget voilà il faut rester comme ça
aller plus loin en enlevant les 49,3 en
dehors des budgets non je pense que que
c'est utile vous savez un seul 49 droit
sur toute une session ordinaire c'est
très peu mais je pense que c'est une
bonne chose et ça correspond à ce que
vous décrivez sur la perception qu'on
les Français de cet outil alors
transition toute trouvée pour aller sur
le terrain des institutions est-ce que
c'est ce 49-3 sur les retraites que les
Français rejettent ou le 49-3 qui ne
peuvent plus supporter parce qu'il
réclament davantage de de place dans la
décision publique on va aborder toutes
ces questions avec vous Loïc Blondieau
mais d'abord pour se figurer un petit
peu des choses on est allé au reportage
avec avec vous il y a le droit de Pivet
dans les Yvelines aux Mureaux et c'est
Elsa vont d'un Gava qui vous a suivi
vous allez le voir c'est très clair on
le retrouve là encore et toujours ce
fameux 49 3 regardez je pense que le
49.3 c'est à peu près l'équivalent de
Lady royal de de il y a 300 ans et ça
c'est inadmissible ne vous étonnez pas
que les gens n'aillent plus voter qu'il
n'est plus confiance parce que nos
politiques ont pris l'habitude de nous
trahir pour moi la base c'est de
supprimer le 4
9 parce
[Musique]
que pour son mécontentement et ben ce
que le président a décidé c'est ce qui
se fera donc pour moi c'est la base
c'est de supprimer le 49.3 voilà donc
pour ces Paroles de Français dans votre
circonscription il y a le Braun Pivet
voilà c'est très clair ce 49-3 il en
veulent plus comment vous interprétez
cette demande est-ce que c'est sur cette
réforme ou est-ce que il faut maintenant
peut-être envisager de recoudre la
Constitution différemment à partir des
demandes sociales exprimées je crois que
les Français expriment vraiment beaucoup
ce désir de participer à la prise de
décision ils veulent ils se
reconnaissent plus ou moins dans leur
représentants et on pourrait en parler
sur le mode de scrutin etc mais en fait
il ne conçoivent plus leurs citoyenneté
comme uniquement l'acte d'aller voter
désigner un représentant ils veulent
également participer à la construction
de la décision et parfois décidé
eux-mêmes et c'est pour ça que moi je
propose d'aller très loin de France
de consultation et de participation
citoyenne je crois que ça c'est un des
éléments qui permettrait de revivifier
la démocratie quant à l'usage de 49-3 à
nouveau il est très encadré et il me
semble que dans un contexte de majorité
relative nous n'avons pas le choix
faut continuer à faire cette pédagogie
mais il faut continuer à lamentablement
parce que en même temps les Français
voyaient ils sont ambivalent puisque ils
se satisfont de la majorité relative et
en fait un gouvernement majorité absolue
n'a pas besoin de 49,3 peut-être que
c'était en majorité
donc voilà allez on en vient à vous Loïc
Blondieau on y est le chantier des
institutions la Cinquième République
était la bout de souffle en tout cas
dans les cortèges dans les retraites on
a vu très vite après le 49.3 basculer
les mots d'ordre les slogans sur sur la
question institutionnelle vous étiez
garant de la convention citoyenne pour
le climat vous avez beaucoup travaillé
sur la démocratie participative et elle
brune Pivet fait une proposition une
journée de consultation un premier
dimanche par mois peut-être nos parents
pardon dans dans l'année peut-être en
octobre pour faire toute une série de
consultations au niveau de national au
niveau local qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez non je pense qu'il y a vraiment
une urgence au-delà même de la question
de la 5e République des institutions du
49-3 il y a une urgence de la question
démocratique elle-même aujourd'hui on
voit que la désaffection vis-à-vis de du
gouvernement des représentants le
sentiment de ne plus être représenté ou
d'être mal représenté de la part des
citoyens le l'augmentation du niveau
d'abstention montre un affaiblissement
majeur de la démocratie et en même temps
une demande très très paradoxale on a vu
le mouvement des gilets jaunes
leur demande principale c'était le RIC
c'était avoir la possibilité de peser
sur la décision on a des outils cette
convention citoyenne alors j'étais
membre du comité de gouvernance j'étais
pas exactement garant mais à montrer que
les citoyens étaient prêts 150 citoyens
étaient prêts à travailler à à
construire l'intérêt général des en
position d'intérêt général et l'on fait
dans une ambiance dans une qualité de
délibération tout à fait extraordinaire
associé le citoyen aujourd'hui Albert
Camus disait quand la démocratie est
malade le fascisme vient à son cheval
mais c'est pas pour demander de ses
nouvelles et aujourd'hui on voit
l'extrême droite partout dans le monde
c'est pas uniquement en France être là
pour récupérer la mise et on ne sait pas
ce que vont devenir nos démocraties et
pour moi la centralité de la question
démocratique elle est liée aussi à ce
qui va nous arriver regarde la
transition écologique on pourra pas
mener la transition écologique sans
associer les citoyens et paradoxalement
et c'est ça le paradoxe et c'est
là-dessus que je voudrais interroger
madame Brown Pivet on a l'impression que
cette question elle est pas à l'agenda
réellement la réforme des institutions
elle est un peu enlisée je suis pas sûr
que les propositions qui ont été mises
sur la table pour l'instant soit à la
hauteur des défis et la question alors
qu'il y a plein de possibilités ouvrir
le référendum
la présentation proportionnelle
l'inversion du calendrier ça demanderait
pas grand chose du calendrier électoral
ça changerait tout faire voter aux
élections législatives avant ou le même
jour de voter l'élection présidentielle
on change complètement l'équilibre de
nos institutions pourquoi dans certains
points de vue ça n'est pas à ce point
pour vous une urgence parce que la
conviction qu'on peut avoir c'est que la
démocratie représentative qui est
particulièrement malade ne pourra se
sauver que par plus de démocratie sinon
elle devra laisser la place à autre
chose bien sûr mais je suis entièrement
d'accord avec vous c'est la conviction
que j'ai aujourd'hui moi j'ai entamé un
tour de France pour parler à nos
concitoyens de la démocratie et de ces
questions démocratiques et pas plus tard
qu'hier j'étais encore dans le
Pas-de-Calais avant-hier dans le
Pas-de-Calais pour discuter donc oui moi
je suis convaincu que nos concitoyens
ont ce besoin de participation et donc
il faut il faut l'organiser est-ce que
ça passe par une grande réforme la
constitutionnel je ne suis pas sûr il y
a des sujets constitutionnels et vous
les avez évoqués l'ouverture du chant du
référendum de l'article 11 passe par une
révision constitutionnelle si on veut
moderniser le référendum d'initiative
partagée ça passe par une réforme
constitutionnelle si on veut aller plus
loin dans la réforme du Conseil
économique social et environnemental que
nous ne l'avons fait en lui confiant la
possibilité d'organiser les conventions
citoyennes il faut une révision
constitutionnelle ou aller plus loin
dans la décentralisation pour mieux
savoir parce que ça ça revient beaucoup
qui fait quoi qui est responsable de
quoi c'est quelque chose qui revient
beaucoup chez nos compatriotes ils ne
comprennent pas bien je vous avoue que
parfois moi non plus donc et on ne va
pas voter si on ne sait pas pourquoi on
vote le problème c'est que la réforme
constitutionnelle c'est très compliqué
exactement il faut quasiment impossible
les deux tiers départemental avec le
Sénat qui a un droit de veto c'est très
compliqué dans le système mais il y a
plein de voix d'action qui ne sont pas
constitutionnels vous les avez évoqués
aussi si l'on change le mode de scrutin
parlementaires c'est une loi ordinaire
c'est une loi ordinaire nous n'avons pas
besoin d'une majorité des trois
cinquièmes sinon vous allez proposer
parce que moi je propose les élections
le même jour oui pourquoi pas je suis
plus favorable à cette situation là te
dire le même en fait la dynamique
présidentielle qui au fond emporte tout
sur son passage tout à fait au
législatif derrière moi ça me semble que
d'une part ça renforcerait le rôle du
Parlement que d'autre part ça a assuré
une meilleure représentation de
l'ensemble des partis politiques puisque
ça ne serait pas biaisé par l'élection
présidentielle et puis on aurait un
avantage mathématique c'est qu'on
augmenterait des facto la participation
aux législatif puisque l'élection
présidentielle est l'ultime élection à
laquelle nos Français nos compatriotes
participent puisqu'on a plus de 80% de
participation à l'élection
présidentielle là où on tombe plutôt aux
environs de 50% pour les législatives si
vous les faites le même jour
mécaniquement vous augmentez la
participation au législatives et donc
vous renforcer la légit des députés
la fixation des jours des élections
dépend du pouvoir exécutif ministère de
l'intérieur des élections
ça dépend de l'exécutif et de dire par
exemple je parlais du jour de
consultation on n'a pas besoin de faire
de réformes constitutionnelle il suffit
de le décider le président de la
République peut décider de faire un
référendum et on peut collectivement
avec les mers les conseillers les
Présidents de Conseils départementaux et
régionaux se dire et bien oui allons-y
lanceons-nous dans ce jour de la
consultation et trouvons des sujets
locaux et nationaux à soumettre à nos
compatriotes nous n'avons pas besoin de
réforme pour cela pas de réforme au fond
une journée le seuil du référendum
d'initiative partagé serait abaissé
c'est ce que vous proposez aussi pour
que on puisse le déclencher plus
facilement et puis pourquoi pas
permettre aux citoyens de faire des
référendums comme il y en a par exemple
en Suisse à différents échelons bien sûr
pas besoin de loi tout à fait
la défiance historique en France à
gauche et à droite vis-à-vis du
référendum puis surtout l'histoire
plébiscitaire du référendum le fait que
il a été utilisé notamment par De Gaulle
comme un plébiscite bon empêche que le
référendum devienne une sorte de de
possible politique et entre dans la dans
le quotidien la vie politique c'est ce
qui se passe en Suisse certes les
Suisses votent finalement assez peu au
référendum mais la seule le simple
sentiment de pouvoir être à l'origine de
de d'une votation ou le fait d'être
consulté sur des sujets importants et
devrait nous nous faire croire que c'est
possible réconcilie aussi
les Français sont demandeurs de
référendum qui soit d'initiés du
citoyenne on retient ça pas besoin de
changer la constitution après
journée de consultation une fois par an
on verra comment chemine votre
proposition vous restez avec moi merci à
vous dans une petite dizaine de minutes
de parties pris deux affranchis ce soir
Yanis roder une nouvelle histoire
d'école notre enseignant d'histoire-géo
préférée de la Fondation Jean Jaurès va
vous interpeller sur le défi des abaya à
l'école et puis le philosophe et
écrivain n'attend de vers vous interroge
sur le complot le complotisme les fake
news et la démocratie mais d'abord on
passe aux questions d'actualité il y a
plein de sujets sur lesquels on a envie
de vous entendre il y a El Braun Pivet a
commencé parce qu'il s'est passé à
Nanterre tour d'horizon en images avec
Marco pommier
nuit d'émeute dans plusieurs villes de
la banlieue parisienne voiture et
poubelles incendiées affrontement avec
les forces de l'ordre après la mort de
Naël 17 ans tué hier matin par un
policier pour refus d'obtempérer le
fonctionnaire a été placé en garde à vue
deux enquêtes ont été ouvertes dont
l'une confiait à l'IGPN la police des
polices j'ai mal à ma France a réagi
Kylian Mbappe Emmanuel Macron en appel
au calme nous avons un adolescent qui
qui a été tué cette inexplicable une
excusable et d'abord je ce sont des mots
d'affection de peine partagée de soutien
à sa famille et à ses proches
c'est la crainte des journalistes du
Journal du Dimanche en grève depuis 6
jours il dénonce l'arrivée de Geoffroy
Lejeune à la tête de leur rédaction
marqué à l'extrême droite l'ancien
directeur de la rédaction de valeur
actuelle était un soutien d'Éric Zemmour
à la dernière présidentielle derrière
cette nomination polémique l'ombre de
Vincent Bolloré nouveau propriétaire du
journal on espère en tous les cas que ce
qui nous arrive aujourd'hui sera un
électrochoc pour toutes les rédactions
rédaction de France c'est-à-dire qu'on
est même contacté par des rédactions
européennes allemandes italienne qui
s'inquiète en fait de cette de cette
montée rampante d'idées xénophobe qui
sont pas les idées véhiculées par le JDD
4 jours après la tentative
d'insurrection de la milice Wagner menée
par Prigogine les diplomaties
occidentales sont dans le flou avec
cette question le maître du Kremlin
sorti le renforcé ou affaibli par cette
rébellion avortée
alors on va évidemment commencer par le
drame de Nanterre il y a eu plusieurs
incidences cette nuit 24 interpellations
et la mort d'un jeune homme de 17 ans à
la suite de ce possible refus
d'obtempérer l'enquête est en cours un
policier et étant garde à vue et cette
minute de silence aujourd'hui elle était
fondamentale que la représentation
nationale ça s'arrête et facilement en
hommage à Maëlle 17 ans tué par un
policier oui c'est son des moments
importants ce sont des moments poignants
et c'est ce que nous devons
aux victimes
et lorsque l'émotion saisit un pays il
est fondamental que cette émotion
traverse les murs de l'Assemblée
nationale et que l'hémicycle puisse
également
s'associer cette émotion et à la douleur
de des familles l'émotion saisit le pays
les réactions sont très nombreuses des
footballeurs comme Kylian Mbappe disent
qu'ils ont mal à leur France aujourd'hui
le comédien
Omar Sy aussi sanding il va falloir
attendre évidemment les résultats de
l'enquête mais les mots du président de
la République sont extrêmement forts il
dit que c'est une excusable inexplicable
et inexcusable comme acte
il va évidemment falloir laisser
l'enquête se faire moi ce que j'observe
c'est que le la les faits qui sont
reprochés aujourd'hui aux policiers
c'est de l'homéde volontaire il est en
garde à vue actuellement et donc on voit
bien que les autorités ont saisi la
mesure de ce qui s'était passé
maintenant donc moi je je
aujourd'hui
c'est la crainte de l'embrasement des
banlieues on le sait c'est une
possibilité vous le redoutez mais oui et
je vois bien que même dans ma
circonscription il y a eu des événements
cette nuit et donc on voit bien que
l'indignation
s'empare de nos jeunes et bien au-delà
dans toutes les familles c'est un enfant
de 17 ans qui est décédé donc il faut
que toute la lumière soit faite il faut
qu'il y ait cette émotion et il faut
aussi que nous restions calmes parce que
nous faisons société ensemble et ça
n'est pas en provoquant des heures en
attisant les flammes parfois que l'on
règlera cette situation alors qu'il y a
eu des moments très forts dans
l'hémicycle une écologie d'hier a dit
chlorophytoptempéries n'est pas passible
de la peine de mort c'est une loi de
2017 juste avant l'élection d'Emmanuel
Macron sur les critères justifiant
l'usage d'une arme à feu qui est en
cause aujourd'hui très clairement est-ce
qu'il va falloir faire le bilan de
l'application de cette loi ecoutez
pourquoi pas moi je je pense que c'est
utile moi je crois beaucoup en
l'évaluation de la loi d'une façon
générale il est important une fois que
nous avons voté un texte que nous
regardions si le texte finalement
atteint les objectifs que nous avons
poursuivi et donc regardez si un texte
est bien fait si il fonctionne s'il
permet d'atteindre nos objectifs et
utile donc moi je souhaiterais
effectivement qu'on puisse évaluer cette
et refonder toute la police comme on le
dit
il faut il faut rentrer dans la
complexité des choses il faut rentrer
dans la nuance moi je suis là en fait de
ce qui jettent des annatèmes sur les uns
ou sur les autres nos policiers font un
travail remarquable et ils sont ils
doivent être le plus rigoureux possible
et là il faudra regarder s'ils étaient
bien dans le cadre d'emploi mais ne
jetons pas l'eau propre sur des groupes
vidéos des témoins pour l'instant
laisse penser que laissons l'enquête
c'est bien pour cela que le l'émotion on
va parler à présent de ce qui se passe
au Journal du Dimanche 4 questions au
Gouvernement hier dans l'hémicycle et
beaucoup députés y compris dans la
majorité ont signé la tribune de soutien
aux journalistes en grève pas vous
pourquoi j'imagine que vous avez été
sollicité j'ai été sollicitée par
principe en fait en tant que président
de l'Assemblée nationale je m'interdis
de signer des tribunes donc sur quelques
sujets que ce soit donc il ne faut pas
Côte d'Ivoire un désaccord de ma part au
contraire j'ai publiquement soutenu le
Journal du Dimanche
l'ancien directeur de valeurs actuelles
dont je rappelle qu'il avait été
condamné pour un jurassiste pour un une
représentation sur une députée qui siège
ici sur les bancs insoumise Daniel obono
représentée en esclave avec chaîne au
cou je me souviens très bien de cette
une qui était effectivement très
choquante ce qui doit tous nous
inquiéter c'est le fait que l'on puisse
douter peut-être de l'indépendance de
telle ou tel média des médias d'opinion
ça a toujours existé et c'est bien
normal qu'il y en ait après il faut que
les rédactions soient totalement
indépendantes et il faut également
s'assurer de la pluralité des de ces
mêmes opinions alors comment
concentration des médias il y a des
aides publiques aussi qui sont versées
aux JDD certains députés disent qu'il
faut légiférer permettre une forme de
veto des rédactions dans les nominations
des directeurs de rédaction c'est comme
le cas au monde par exemple par exemple
il y a un énorme sujet on le voit il y a
un énorme sujet on voit que les lois
successives doivent mérites d'être
probablement revisité il y a eu
plusieurs missions que ce soit à
l'Assemblée nationale ou au Sénat sur ce
sujet donc les parlementaires sont à
pieds d'oeuvre mais ce qui doit être
visité doit l'être parce que je crois
que c'est important parce que nous
devons garantir dans un état
démocratique la pluralité des médias et
l'indépendance des journalistes et des
rédactions deux petites questions avant
d'accueillir nos affranchis j'imagine
que vous avez été scotchés comme nous
tous samedi voyons cette colonne de
blindée emmenée par Prigogine montée
vers Moscou avec ce putsch avorté
aujourd'hui c'est cramator ce qu'on
Ukraine qui est bombardé par un missile
russe qu'est-ce que vous pensez de cette
situation est-ce qu'il est pas urgent
d'aider encore plus les Ukrainiens alors
je suis très inquiète parce qu'on voit
que la situation est très instable et
cela donne aux préoccuper au plus haut
point je monte je m'entretiendrai tout à
l'heure avec mon homologue de la Rada
sur cette situation plus que jamais oui
il faut être en soutien des Ukrainiens
les armées davantage et que les armes
arrivent plus vite leur fournir tout ce
dont ils ont besoin c'est fondamental
vous restez avec moi Yaël brune Pivet
c'est donc l'heure d'accueillir nos
affranchis pour leur parti pris ils vont
vous interpeller on les accueille tout
de suite Yanis roder bienvenue et Nathan
de verre qui enseigne la philosophie à
Bordeaux et qui est écrivain Yanis qui
enseigne l'histoire-géographie en
Seine-Saint-Denis de la Fondation Jean
Jaurès ça y est vous êtes installé on
commence avec vous carte blanche c'est
parti Yanis on vous écoute je voulais
vous alerter sur un sujet que l'on
croyait révolue le port de vêtements à
l'école manifestant une appartenance
religieuse et notamment les abayas
depuis un an des jeunes filles sont de
plus en plus nombreuses à porter ce type
de vêtements jusqu'à se compter par
dizaines dans certains établissements on
parle de 150 à 180 par exemple dans des
lycées de Lyon ou Vénissieux par sa
circulaire du 9 novembre 2022 le
ministre de l'éducation nationale a
réagi est venu en aide au chef
d'établissement mais la situation sur le
terrain demeure parfois compliquée car
non seulement la banane n'est pas un
signe religieux par nature mais
également parce que des jeunes filles
utilisent des éléments de langage
d'ailleurs les mêmes à Grenoble Toulouse
et à Lille c'est intéressant qui font de
ce vêtement en fait un signe culturel et
non cultuel certains appellent donc
aujourd'hui de leurs vœux une nouvelle
loi bien que Monsieur papel Ndiaye se
soit dit opposé à cela ou même à une
évolution de la loi de 2004
personnellement je pense que le ministre
a raison mais cette lecture vous l'avez
compris n'est pas unanimement partagée
j'aurais souhaité madame la Présidente
avoir votre avis sur la question
moi je suis très inquiète je viens de
faire un déplacement dans le
Pas-de-Calais et j'ai des élus qui m'ont
dit que
au moment du Ramadan il y avait des
parents qui demandaient dans des écoles
primaires à ce que les enfants n'aillent
pas à la cantine et que on prenne en
charge la surveillance de ses enfants
puisqu'il n'était pas à la cantine ça
nécessitait d'une surveillance
supplémentaire
moi je ne veux pas de cette France là
moi je veux d'une école publique
parfaitement laïque où il n'y a pas de
Ramadan où il n'y a pas d'abaya où il
n'y a pas de signe
ostensible religieux je veux que ce
lieu-là par dessus tout soit préservé
pas besoin de changer la loi pour ça
alors après pour qu'il soit préservé il
faut être très clair sur les valeurs que
l'on porte moi tous mes enfants sont
dans l'école publique
c'est important pour moi mais parce que
je crois en l'école publique je crois
dans une école publique qui permet
justement à chacun d'avoir de ne pas
subir d'influence
et donc moi s'il fallait faire une loi
pour rappeler tout ça et faire en sorte
que nos enseignants et que les
directeurs d'établissement et nos mères
ne soient pas en difficulté face à ces
situations je n'hésiterai pas à voter
une telle loi mais en tout cas moi je
suis très inquiète et je ne veux pas que
la religion pénètre comme ça dans ces
espaces là retour à la loi possible
merci il y a le brune Pivet pour cette
annonce on verra ce qu'il en est dans
les dans les jours qui viennent dans les
semaines qui viennent d'ailleurs on
attend une décision de conseil d'État
sur les hitabus dans le football demain
Nathan c'est vous qui terminez Nathan de
verre qui enseigne la philosophie
voulait vous parler de démocratie à
l'heure des fake news et du complotisme
exactement bonsoir Je voulais vous poser
une question sur un phénomène qui est
majeur de notre époque qui est le
complotisme qui à la fois engendre une
polarisation de la société et qui me
semble-t-il creuse un gouffre entre les
citoyens et et les élus alors il y a une
étude de d'avril 2023 Ipsos qui a montré
que 35% des Français donc c'est quand
même énorme à des romans à une théorie
du complot et parfois plus que ce soit
sur le 11 septembre sur la guerre en
Ukraine sur le réchauffement climatique
etc il me semble qu'il y a un paradoxe
fondamental dans le phénomène du
complotisme c'est que d'une part et tout
le monde sera d'accord me semble-t-il
pour dire que le complotisme 1000 la
démocratie mine la possibilité d'un
débat démocratique parce que le débat
démocratique repose sur la distinction
entre des vérités de raison que des
citoyens n'est pas les mêmes opinions
les mêmes avis les mêmes appartenance
idéologiques c'est normal et les vérités
de fait tout le monde doit être d'accord
pour dire qu'il a été élu aux dernières
élections présidentielles si on
relativise et si on mélange les faits et
les opinions alors là il y a plus de
débats démocratique possible mais
d'autre part et à mon avis c'est tout le
paradoxe du complotisme c'est que le
complotisme sa condition de possibilité
c'est la démocratie à savoir c'est le
fait que il y a une liberté de
conscience qu'il y a une liberté
d'opinion et que l'État n'a pas
légiférer sur ce que pense les gens
quand bien même penserait-il mal et
surtout quand bien même penserait-il
faux alors ma question elle est double
premièrement en tant que élu et que
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale
comment avait enfin quel rapport
avez-vous presque fin d'expérience du
complotisme et deuxièmement comment
lutter contre le complotisme sans
entraver la liberté d'opinion vous avez
au moins
non mais c'est très c'est une question
très complexe parce que pour rencontrer
beaucoup les citoyens lors de réunions
publiques ou lors de mes déplacements je
vois bien qu'il est parfaitement
impossible parfois de réussir à
dialoguer avec des personnes qui sont
très complotistes et que c'est un
dialogue de sourd on tourne en rond et à
chaque fois qu'on sent qu'on va
convaincre il y a une pirouette et on
voilà ça on y arrive pas et donc je
pense qu'il faut être très inquiet il
faut pour réussir à lutter contre ces
félins je crois développer profondément
l'esprit critique profondément la
culture du débat justement savoir
écouter l'autre savoir débattre
argumenter contre argumenter accepter de
se laisser convaincre ne pas être sûr
d'avoir raison envers et contre tout on
peut se tromper on peut on doit être
capable de changer envie de ne pas
savoir tout surtout de raisonner parfois
faux il faut avoir cette humilité là je
crois que ça c'est important et puis se
dit ne prendre ne rien prendre pour
argent comptant surtout à un moment où
on voit que avec maintenant
l'intelligence artificielle on peut
fabriquer des images fabriquer des
vidéos en un
laps de temps très bref qui ont tout
l'apparence de la réalité et donc il
faut impérativement parce que vous avez
raison on va pas maîtriser l'information
ce n'est pas possible et ça n'est
peut-être pas souhaitable donc il faut
en fait ne pas maîtriser la source mais
finalement maîtriser celui qui reçoit
cette information pour que lui il soit
capable de la recevoir avec un esprit le
plus éclairé possible et donc il faut
qu'il doute et donc on revient aux
enseignants que que vous êtes pardon je
vous ai à peu pressé c'était un peu
chargé merci beaucoup merci beaucoup
madame miel brun Pivet présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale qui fait donc sa
première année d'élection au perchoir
c'est la fin de cette émission tout de
suite votre soirée documentaire
Jean-Pierre Gratien à demain même le
même heure
[Musique]